wait how zoomed in are you the Internet
is good for many things but providing
trusted advice on natural remedies is
definitely not one of them especially
when it comes to apple cider vinegar a
quick google search will show you that
people use it for everything from
cleaning their teeth to curing yeast
infections so if people on the Internet
are doing it it's worth trying right
definitely wrong because not only is
there little evidence to support most of
the uses for apple cider vinegar but
some of them are straight-up
bad for you apple cider vinegar is
basically just fermented juice yeast
turns the sugars and apple juice and
alcohol and bacteria then turns that
alcohol into acetic acid the chemical
linked to most of cider vinegars alleged
benefits but here's the thing this
process isn't unique to apple cider
vinegar in fact acetic acid is in all
types of vinegar from white wine to
balsamic the main thing that makes cider
vinegar different is that it might be
easier to swallow than a straight-up
swig of balsamic and if you are so
inclined to gulp it down there's at
least one benefit you can look forward
to
research shows that drinking cider
vinegar after a meal may help lower your
blood sugar levels so studies have
demonstrated that when people eat a high
starch meal and follow it with a little
bit of apple cider vinegar the blood
sugars and after eating those meals may
not go up as much compared to when you
eat placebo that's dr. and trained chef
edwin mcdonald he says that ingesting as
little as 20 grams of apple cider
vinegar has been shown to slow the
release of food from your stomach into
your intestines that's where your body
breaks down starches like pasta into
sugars and as a result you're not gonna
throw up those sugars as quickly so when
you don't absorb sugars as quickly your
instant levels or they don't rise to
much and your blood sugar get a surprise
as much and that's great news for anyone
who's diabetic or pre-diabetic
despite what you read online it probably
won't help you lose weight I also run a
weight management clinic and this
question comes up all the time but
lowering your blood sugar after a meal
is just about the only benefit of
drinking apple cider vinegar research
does suggest that acetic acid can slow
down the accumulation of body fat and
prevent metabolic disorders in mice and
rats but there's little evidence that it
has the same effect on humans in one
weight loss experiment three volunteers
drank two tablespoons of either apple
cider vinegar malt vinegar or a placebo
drink twice a day for two months
straight and none of them lost weight in
an older study with a similar design
participants did lose weight but only
about 1/3 of a pound each week which
McDonald says isn't much but if not for
weight loss what about using cider
vinegar to whiten your teeth I caution
people against that
that's because cider vinegar is an acid
in fact most brands have a pH between 2
and 3 which is similar to stomach acid
so swishing it around in your mouth can
over time wear down the enamel around
your teeth leaving them feeling rough to
the touch and more susceptible to
cavities and decay yikes then there are
the people who use apple cider vinegar
as a shampoo replacement and as it turns
out there is actually a pretty good
reason for that because cider vinegar is
so acidic dr. McDonald says it can kill
some of the microbes that make your hair
stink and it can also limit the
population of a type of fungus that can
lead to dandruff but there's a flip side
because cider vinegar is so acidic it
can also burn or irritate your scalp so
you should always dilute it with water
oh and despite what you read online
cider vinegar is not effective against
head lice in fact one study found that
among six home remedies that people use
to eliminate lice like olive oil and
mayonnaise apple cider vinegar is the
least effective none of them work though
the claims of what apple cider vinegar
can do don't stop there just keep in
mind that at least for now
none of them is supported by a large
body of scientific research now of
course we're not talking about taste
when it comes to cooking there's no
uncertainty apple cider vinegar is
delicious I use it all the time when
making dressing pickle
and sauces yes I cook I just don't walk
away from me linking I've just swallowed
some ultimate cure-all
[Music]